il cuore rallenta e la terra sta cammina
in quel pozzo di piscio e il cemento a
quel campo strappato dal vento
a forza di essere vento porto il nome di
tutti i battesimi ogni nome il sigillo
di un lasciapassare per un guado una
terra una nuvola un canto un diamante
nascosto nel pane per un solo dolcissimo
umore del sangue per la stessa ragione
del ghiaccio viaggiare
[Musica]
cuore allenta la testa cammina
io non muoio di giostre in disuso è
chiaro si è affermato italiano gomorra
mea imbrunire sul mondo
saper leggere il libro del mondo con
parole cangianti e nessuna scrittura nei
sentieri costretti in un palmo di mano i
segreti che fanno paura
[Musica]
fin da un uomo ti incontra non si
riconosce e ogni terra si accende serena
la pace
[Musica]
i segni cadevano da un calendario
jugoslavia polonia i soldati prendevano
tutti
il totti buttano
via e poi mirka al san giorgio di maggio
tra le fiamme dei fiori a ridere a bere
e un sollievo di lacrime a invadere gli
occhi ed agli occhi
ora alzate sposa bambina che è venuto il
tempo di andare con le vene celesti dei
polsi
anche oggi si va carità
e se questo vuol dire rubare questo filo
di pane tra miseria fortuna allo
specchio di questa campina ai miei occhi
limpidi come un addio lo può dire
soltanto che sa di raccogliere in bocca
il punto di vista di dio
[Musica]
c'ero pochi ei che rava new york sono
morti
mi pare gli enti a conca st a
il barone bovini un oblò comoda la donò
bla bla conosco vini palla balla
[Musica]
[Applauso]